hello everyone thank you for coming my
name is Natalia andriichuk and I'm a
statistical data scientist at our center
of excellence and today I'm here to talk
about what it takes to build a community
of engaged our users and how we approach
this
advisor but first let me take a step
back and answer the question of why
building Community was important for us
here's my favorite quote from Alice in
Wonderland my dear here we must run as
fast as we can if uh just to stay in
place and if we want to go anywhere you
must run twice as fast as that and in my
opinion this perfectly describes what's
happening in the Pharma world when it
comes to adoption of R and I won't be
diving into details of why this is
happening I just want to let you know
that fiser is not an exception and our
adoption happening
fast
so building the community connecting
people and their experiences is very
vital for
success but what if we approached
building the community like the readme
file for our project or package uh
readme file is very essential and I'm
sure a lot of you in this room either
interacted with the readme file or
created one this is the first file that
programmers read when they actually
approach project so let's look at the
typical structure of the readme file
together and I'll let you know how this
translates into the community building
terms when you open the readme file the
first thing you look for is the
installation instructions how to install
the package is it on cran is it on
GitHub are there any dependencies you
have to um take into account this is the
foundational knowledge you need to
obtain in order to move forward with you
know installing the package you can't
move forward without that and in the
community building terms this translates
into establishing the foundation for
your
community and to be successful in it you
need to assemble a dedicated team of
colleagues who will take on the
community building project and will make
it their priority and we do have such
team ADV viser and I'm very lucky to be
a part of it and advisor we have the r
uh SWAT team this is our SWAT team it's
part of a bigger rcoe uh team and the
SWAT stands for scientific workflows and
analytic tools we're very proud of This
Acronym we are the internal consultancy
group for those parts of organizations
that don't have experts on hand so where
they are experts and on top of that we
are the professional Community
Builders building the the community is
not our site project this is one of our
priorities so we have the community
building initiatives in our semester
goals and we treat it as a project
deliverables because if we w't do that
then there always will be the project
that going to supersede Community
Building initiatives and the process
would be
slow however it's very important to
acknowledge that we um won't be able to
make the progress that we made without
the help of our it experts because we're
Our Community Builders and we need our
infrastructure to achieve our goals and
the goals of our
colleagues at fiser we use a suite of
professional tools uh to support our
projects and our it experts support all
of them and the SWAT Team Works closely
to with it to define the best practices
we also have regular check-ins to
address any questions or concerns we as
a team have and our colleagues have so
we're this connector between our
programmers and the IT
department and the relationships we
established with the it colleagues help
us to support our our
community having tools is great but we
all know that we need a proper
documentation for those tools and we
needed a single source of truth and the
single source of documentation where our
colleagues can access all the
documentation regardless of where they
are in the world at any given time so
for us the Riser Confluence became this
um single source of Truth so the
Confluence website is an internal
website where we host all our
documentation how- to articles we
promote best practices and this is also
the place where our it colleagues post
all their um best practices guides and
information and the rule of thumb is if
we get the same question from multiple
colleagues if a few times we need to
write a knowledge article on it and post
it to the Confluence
website with this we accomplish a few
things so first of all we saving us
ourselves time in the long run because
we only publishing the article once of
course we need to maintain it but the
bulk of work done just once and then the
second thing is that everyone will get
the same uniform advice to the question
they ask the advice that we as a team
agreed on if this is Consolidated in the
knowledge
article perfect we went through the
first part of our read me the foundation
part so let's go back to the typical
package read me and um see what the next
section is and the next section is usage
so you install the package and now it's
time to dive in and learn what the key
functionality of your package and learn
what are the key functions of the
package are and in the community
building terms this translates into
creating delivering and maintaining
proper training for your colleagues
everyone's learning approach is
different and everybody can be in
different places when it it comes to
their art Journey so it was very
important for us to create uh deliver
training that will fit
everyone we all learn programming by
doing therefore we create the series of
uh Hands-On mini projects where our
colleagues can get their hands dirty so
far we have uh 13 R projects those are
the r markdown files and each R markdown
file dedicated to a specific topic can
be um how to create a function or
visualize um the data and all of the
exercises are relevant to uh clinical
programming so they're relevant to our
colleagues day-to-day job trainees can
access those exercises at any given time
and they can perform them and complete
the challenge at the end at their own
pace
it's also important to learn from
experts therefore we make an effort to
once in a while uh invite the expert
from posit or within our own fiser
organization and they can come in and
give a training on a dedicated topic
again it can be a workflow or a package
and then we record all those sessions
those are typically one to two hour
sessions and then we posted to Microsoft
teams Channel and we have bunch of
recordings so we SE divided them into
sections for example Master the ti
diverse training sections um sessions
are the videos where each recording
dedicated to for example the Tidy verse
package and the r for beginners those
are the videos with the beginner uh
friendly topics they're very short
videos
actually however we all know that R is
moving fast so you recorded the training
today you post it and then tomorrow they
release the new version of uh this
package or the the new function so we
have a couple of initiatives to keep our
colleagues updated in the function of
the week initiative we highlight and we
post about the function we want to
highlight and we find it very useful in
day-to-day programmers life and in the
package of the month initiative every uh
month or every other month we release a
a little training the r markdown for the
package of the month that colleagues can
download and go
through we also utilize a form of
newsletters to distribute knowledge so
there are two types of newsletters we
distribute advances INR newsletter is
the one that highlights latest and
greatest in our community and in our
tools and it also Pharma tailored so
it's uh very fizer focused and in
external Outreach newsletter our
colleagues who are involved in external
initiatives like fuse our Consortium
they highlight their groups latest
updates upcoming events and the working
group progress
perfect we finished the second section
section of our read me and now let's
move on to the last and my favorite p uh
part on how to contribute back so in
your typical read me package uh there's
always a section on how to contribute
back because open source project
projects they encourage collaboration
and they encourage Innovation and maybe
you downloaded the package you played
with it a bit and then you found a book
and you want to um propos the solution
or maybe you would want want request the
feature and in the community building
terms this actually perfect as is that
doesn't translate um and I want to
emphasize that I noticed this is a
common misconception that you have to be
a seasoned programmer um in order to
contribute back to the community and in
order and to prove that this is not true
I want to show you a quick
example this is the issue tab of the
GitHub page for the for the very
well-known package use this and you can
see there are a lot of issues filed for
this package this package is used by
thousands of programmers and each issue
has a tag Associated and amongst those
tags you can find a good first issue
this shows that even the most complex
projects that uh they have tasks that
can be achieved and uh um that can be
done by beginner programmers so by
picking up this issue working on it and
contributing the results of your work
back you're helping yourself you're
learning new things as well as helping
programmers who are developing the
package and programmers who going to use
this package we kept this in mind as
Community Builders when we were creating
the initiatives and tools where our
colleagues can contribute back so let's
take a look at a few of
those first and foremost anyone can join
the Riser Microsoft teams ch Channel
comprising over
1,00 um colleagues so far it's a great
resource for sharing news and answering
and asking questions and sometimes when
you're battling the programming issue it
might seem like you're the only one in
this world facing this very Niche issue
but a lot of times you're not there's
always someone out there who already
solved this issue and has a solution for
you or there's someone who's battling
the same issue and you can join forces
and look for the solution together
so by asking the question on Microsoft
teams Channel our colleagues getting
closer to solving the issues they have
and then once they build the expertise
they can also contribute to the
community give back and assist others by
answering their
questions another great initiative I
would like to highlight one of my
favorites is the book club we
established the book club earlier this
year and we um picked rord data sence
second edition book and this is a great
Initiative for our colleagues to
collaborate and um put the time
dedicated to learning new things in
their their day-to-day schedule so we
initially had 130 people sign uh sign up
for the book club and our colleagues
were divided into 14 different groups
and the geography for those groups
spends from North America through Europe
to Asia and we divided those groups so
that it's the same time zone and also we
have a different expertise level in the
same group for our colleagues and each
group has a dedicated group lead and
throughout the time of like working on
this initiative and leading one of the
groups we uh learned that one of the
biggest obstacle for this particular
initiative is the day job commitments as
the day job commitments increase it
becomes harder for colleagues to join
the session and read the book on a
dedicated uh scheduled basis however for
those teams that became tightnit and for
those colleagues who are very consistent
in reading the book and joining the
session even if they haven't read a
chance haven't had a chance to read the
chapter that week we received an
incredibly positive feedback and
willingness to join book clubs in the
future the community of practice event
is a monthly meeting where we have two
20 minutes presentations followed by 10
minutes questions and this is not an
exclusive event anyone can get in the SC
schedule and showcase their art projects
Lessons Learned and ask for the feedback
uh the presentations vary in scope to
keep all colleagues engaged and this is
a formal event so the presentations are
recorded and they're prepared in advance
um so this is one of the um ways you can
contribute back however there is another
one which is informal event we adopted
the data science Hangout event um read
led by Rachel Dempsey at posit so if you
haven't heard of the data science
hangout it happens every Thursday at
noon Eastern Standard Time and anyone
from the data science Community can join
so please join if you haven't already so
similarly our internal r at fiser
hangout happens every other Wednesday
and anyone from fizer interested in our
programming can join during this event
we invite a featured colleague It's Our
Guest and we asked the uh our colleague
different questions for example um their
our journey what excites them about our
what projects they're working on and
this is the um informal EV so all the
questions are audience L and this is
also not recorded just in case you want
to ask interesting
questions and here you have it we
successfully went through all of the
sections of our read me and now it's
time to summarize why we put so much
effort into creating this community and
building
it building a community is like putting
the puzzle pieces
together it's it's hard at times it's
timec consuming but very rewarding
because engaged Community solves
business problems faster in a more
efficient way by connecting people and
their experiences it promotes knowledge
sharing collaboration innovation
and if you are just starting your
community building Journey or thinking
about one just remember to be patient we
at fiser are trying out different
formats to keep our community engaged
and some of them are getting traction
right away uh others take time to get on
track however we know that being
consistent and persistent and listening
to our colleagues feedback is the key to
figuring out what works best for the
organization and with that I would like
to thank you please feel free to scan
the QR code to connect and view some
other resources that I
linked
than